the ending of John Wick chapter 4 of
surprise fans around the world but the
original ending seriously took them off
be warned spoilers ahead for John Wick
chapter 4.
in many ways John Wick chapter 4 plays
out exactly like the first three films
in the series John Wick sets out on a
killing spree that pits him against some
of the world's greatest assassins
dispatching them in a series of
beautifully choreographed gunfights and
martial arts sequences despite following
the same basic principles as his
predecessors however the ending of John
Wick chapter 4 and dulcerly left plenty
of fans shell-shocked as a seemingly
Invincible John Wick finally succumbs to
his wounds and dies A Warrior's death
although Wick's death is undeniably
shocking director Chad's tehelski claims
that the crew originally tried out an
ending that didn't quite go that far
instead the team went for a more
ambiguous ending that would have left
the Assassins Fades up in the air and
apparently audiences absolutely hated it
stahlski told The Hollywood Reporter
there was a different way to do the
funeral scene and we wanted it to be a
little bit more mysterious so we did one
test screening and the audience revolted
pretty hard about The New Ending so we
thought that we nailed it the first time
and to the Studio's credit they didn't
even blink those tahelski doesn't
clarify exactly what this alternate
ending entailed it's clear that John
Wick's heartbreaking death is much more
powerful than the Izzy or isn't he
finale they originally cooked up filming
the alternate ending wasn't necessary
however because Lion's gate and willing
to kill off its newest Flagship Action
Hero initially bogged at the decision to
kill wake speaking about the decision to
kill a hero that audiences have shown
those signs of being tired of stahlski
says the response was what are you
thinking however the studio was
eventually convinced that ending the
movie with Wick's death was the right
way to go and it seems like many fans
online had a similar reaction One
Twitter user said this movie if its
ending isn't the fake house was
genuinely shocking and I think it worked
really well given what has been built up
throughout the series another said a
shocking Sensational ending this is why
you go to the cinema as daunting as it
must have been for stahelski and Keanu
Reeves to kill off such an iconic
character it's clear that Wick's death
made an immense impact on fans of the
series it's also worth noting that
although Wick's story might be over the
franchise itself lives on with the Anna
De Amos LED John Wick spin-off ballerina
the movie is said to take place sometime
prior to the events of chapter 4. with
Keanu Reeves reportedly making a cameo
appearance in it playing John Wick alive
and well beyond that even though it
appears that John Wick has bit the dust
this is Hollywood talking about
especially in the realm of action
Blockbuster franchises the Mantra never
say never has endured for decades
there's always a way to write around to
death if a filmmaker wants to resurrect
someone badly enough and as fans have
pointed out we don't necessarily see
John die in this world a fake disowned
death scenario feels perfectly within
the realm of possibility and if anyone
could do it it's presumably John Wick
with the massive series best box of his
performance of chapter 4 it would seem
like a major missed opportunity for both
the studio and the audience to stop the
series now but now yeah I'm thinking I'm
back Keanu Reeves certainly doesn't seem
opposed to returning to the role when
the time is right speaking about his
future in the franchise Reeves told
Entertainment Weekly I mean I wouldn't
do a John Wick film without Chad
stachowski would have to see what that
looks like for me it feels really right
that John Wick finds peace Simon tell if
Wick will somehow rise from the grave
for more gun toting sword clanging
action at the movies Beyond John Wick
chapter 4.
foreign